in open court and that he will exercise
his power impartially and
conscientiously and of court pursuant to
article 31 paragraph six of the statute
that same provision applies to judges at
all before inviting mrs. Pillai and mr.
krest to make their solemn declaration I
shall first in accordance with custom
say a few words about their career and
qualifications mr. mrs. Navin Adam
Pillai of South African nationality is a
former judge with a distinguished career
at the national and international levels
after obtaining her law degree at natal
University in South Africa in 1965 she
practices as an attorney for 28 years
inter alia providing legal defense for
opponents of apartheid and handling
seminal cases on the right of political
prisoners just listening there to some
of the opening remarks at the beginning
of this hearing will go back now to our
correspondent way in hey who's just
outside that courtroom in The Hague I
mean walk us through the legal arguments
here that we might be hearing in the
coming days what kind of thresholds well
the prosecutors actually have to cross
in order for Myanmar's actions to be
considered genocide
yes oh it's a good question because
obviously proving a case of genocide is
going to be very difficult it has proven
to be very difficult historically the
Gambians are saying similar things to
what has been said by many other
organizations over the past couple of
years that have conducted extensive
investigations written very detailed
reports about what has happened in
Rakhine State alleging crimes against
humanity alleging genocide including the
United Nations own investigation team
its fact-finding mission found that they
said that there was genocide intent in
some of the actions undertaken by the
security forces in Rakhine State and
also the Myanmar government were the
Gambians on behalf of those oh I see
member nations are saying all of those
things but they're going further as well
saying that not only was there intent
but there were genocide all actions
undertaken by those security forces when
they went through those ruin your
villages are conducting so-called
clearance operations destroying entire
reinga villages murdering raping women
and girls so they are backing up those
claims that be made by many other
organizations many other people and
indeed going a step further when hey in
the hague for us following that trial
thank you Wayne